Netflix's latest original feature
starring Thor himself Chris Hemsworth
alongside Bollywood sensation Ronda
Buddha is about as high-octane a
thriller as any action fan could hope
for through all the captivating action
sequences and frenetic fight scenes
extraction actually manages to tell a
pretty complex story with an ambiguous
ending that has fans abuzz with theories
extraction follows protagonist Tyler
rake a former member of the Australian
Special Air Service regimen
now working as an off-the-books
mercenary other films outset he's
engaged by fellow killer for hire Nick
Kahn to rescue the son of India's
leading drug kingpin who is currently
being held for exorbitant ransom by
rival Bangladeshi drug lord amia who
Seif a hickey of drawing rakes attempted
extraction of his target brings down the
wrath of saju another former special
operative currently in the employ of the
Bangladeshi drug lord break-in Sarge you
engage in a complex game of cat and
mouse but they ultimately end up working
together to outwit the authorities on
their tails as far as action thriller
setups go
it's about as compelling as they come
but viewers hoping for a clear-cut
resolution that sees charismatic
antihero rake Victor is he walking away
from an explosion in slow motion we're
left with the real head-scratcher
let's break extractions I'm pig you
ascending down with a little help from
the film's director Sam Hargrove at the
beginning of the film shark hide
mercenary Tyler Drake has an obvious
death wish his ambivalence towards his
own continued survival is a big part of
what makes him such a deadly murk
we learn that much of Raikes nihilism
stems from the death of a son a loss
that still haunts him it's his
relationship with ovie his target for
extraction that ultimately saves rake
from himself as rake begins to form a
bond with ivy you no longer sees the
drug heir as a simple job but rather a
kid whose life has become more important
than his own can I ask you something
miss Reich what's right my last name by
the time the film reaches as climactic
shoot out on the bridge rake takes a
mortal wound to ensure Ovie's safe
escape this emotional beat lands because
we actually believe that rake no longer
wants to die but us chose him to give up
as
life to save Ovie's so rate guests ago
to its grave feeling like he redeemed
her soul while ovie lives to fight
another day
satisfying ending right not so fast
after Ovie's daring escape the film
presents a very unexpected coda in the
final moments of extraction oh he jumps
into a peaceful swimming ball a mirror
image of rakes first seen jumping off a
cliff when he comes up for air he sees a
blurry figure standing in the background
he bears a striking resemblance to rake
but the film ends before we get any
actual confirmation so what gives as it
turns out extractions final moments were
left open to interpretation by design
Hargrave waited on the mystery
surrounding this final scene
he told Collider we had a version of the
movie and we cesta dare a lot and it was
not surprising that a lot of people
wanted the character to live and some
people wanted him to die if people on
one hand feel at the story is complete
and is a story of redemption through
sacrifice then for them it'll be where
the kid is imagining raike standing
there and then now you go yes I'm
satisfied
Hargrave went on to explain quote if you
feel like you love tyler rake and you
love chris hemsworth and you wants a
sequel and you're like there's no way
you can't kill him then that's tyler
rake standing there looking at you so we
kind of purposefully did not pull focus
to the character standing there the fans
looking for a little more closure
Hargraves share that the original
screenplay for extraction
included a much more definitive ending
in screenwriter Joe Russo's intended
story
Tyler Drake very explicitly dies on the
bridge completing the character arc he
started when he drove off that clear
from the initial scene Hargrave told
Collider that the test audiences weren't
crazy about the sacrifice however he
dashed people were torn
it was almost down the middle we want to
appeal to as many people as possible
without compromising the integrity of
the story and so we think a pretty good
compromises to make an ambiguous ending
our grave ultimately admitted that he
prefers to imagine that rakers dead by
the film's conclusion claiming that he
felt or so recover deemed himself
through sacrifice the fans in desperate
need of finality that's probably the
best you're going to get the rest of us
will have to learn to live with the
ambiguity at least until we get an
extraction to check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos buy your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and at the
well so you don't miss a single one
[Music]